ABOUT SANCTIONS ONE OF THE
THINGS HE SAID THAT THEY ARE
KEEPING SANCTIONS AND A RESERVE.
IT AND I CAN HIT HIM OF THE
TOWN, THEY WANT TO START WITH
MAY BE A TWO, SEE HOW THINGS GO.
OPEN IT UP TO A THREE IF HE GOES
INTO POLAND.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
THAT FLEXIBILITY, DO YOU THINK
THAT THAT IS A GOOD IDEA YOU
THINK WE SHOULD HIT THE RUSSIANS
HARDER OUT OF THE GATE?
>> IF IT IS WHAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED THE WERE SAVING A FEW
BULLETS FOR THE NEXT STEP INTO A
NATO COUNTRY AT HOPE THAT THE
RESPONSE TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN SANCTIONS AT THAT POINT.
THERE IS A BRIGHT LINE, IT IS
THE NATO LINE.
AND AS WE LOOKED EARLIER.
IT APPEARS SHOCKINGLY THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION JESSE HE
IS PUTTING TROOPS ON THE BORDER
OF POLAND.
SO ONCE WE GET TO THE BALTIC
STATE, ONCE WE GET THE POLE AND,
ONCE WE GET TO ROMANIA, WE ARE
TREATY BOUND AT THIS POINT TO
RESPOND MORE HEAVILY THAN WITH
SANCTIONS.
IT'S WHAT WE OF THE FOR?
WERE THOSE BULLETS?
I DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT WE SHOULD
USHER IN.
>> Jesse: HE COULD EXECUTE THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK HE WANTS TO DO SWIFT,
I'LL TELL YOU IS.
WHAT IS THAT MEAN?
>> Dana: AT THE BACK IN TIME
WHEN I FIRST LEARNED WHAT SWIFT
WAS.
I KNOW IDEA WAS ABOUT PUTIN AT
THE TIME BUT IS TRYING TO INVADE
GEORGIA AND THEY GOT PUSHED BACK
OUT OF THERE.
IT'S A FINANCIAL TRANSACTIONS GO
THROUGH AND THINGS USUALLY GO
SMOOTH GRADE BUT YOU CAN TRACK
IT.
AND YOU CAN STOP IT.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT STOPPING
TERRORIST FINANCING THAT WOULD
BE.
EVERYONE NEEDS TO BE SWIFT.
JOE BIDEN CAN'T UNILATERALLY DO
THAT.
YOUR APPEARANCE ARE PART OF THIS
AND AS I UNDERSTAND THIS ITALY,
AND GERMANY ARE QUITE RELUCTANT.
IT DIDN'T WANT TO GO THAT FAR.
SO WE DON'T WANT TO GO THAT FAR,
YOU'RE JUST ALLOWING PUTIN TO
GO, HIS NEXT FAR.
WE GIVE HIM CREDIT HUSBAND JUST
SENT ME A NOTE.
RUSSIANS ARE NOW GOING TO HAVE
TO 15% INTEREST RATES.
AS KAMALA HARRIS SAID, WE ARE
TRYING TO DETER.
NO ONE THOUGHT OSUNA DETER
ANYTHING WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THE PAST THREE MONTHS?
>> Geraldo: SEE YOU TAKE YOUR
ATM CARD AND USE IT IN ITALY, OR
BELGIUM.
>> Jesse: WHAT HAPPENS IF
PUTIN SURROUNDS THE CAPITAL AND
HASKIN TOTAL CONTROL?
AND HE A COUPLE OF WEEKS AND
MANY GAUGES THE PAIN THRESHOLD
OF THE SANCTIONS AND HE SAYS YOU
KNOW WHAT?
DON'T WE FEEL IT THAT MUCH,
WE'VE GOT PLENTY OF MONEY, WERE
TO MOVE NOW.
THAT'S NOT LOOK LIKE A HUGE
STRATEGIC MISCALCULATION ON THE
JOE BIDEN A ADMINISTRATION.
>> Geraldo: I AGREE WITH YOUR
IMPLIED HARDER LINE.
I THINK WE COULD'VE HAD A HARDER
LINE.
WE TALK ABOUT WARPED NARRATIVES,
THE MOST WARPED NARRATIVE IS
THAT PUTIN HAS SOLD THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE THAT HE IS DEAN NOT
DEFYING UKRAINE THE ONLY COUNTRY
THAT HAS A JEWISH LEADER OUTSIDE
OF ISRAEL.
HE IS A PUNK, CRAIG KNIGHT WAS
IN AFGHANISTAN BACK IN 1980.
BIG OLD RUSSIAN ARMY ROLLING
INTO AFGHANISTAN.
THEY ARE GONNA TAKE OVER,
THEY'RE IN A SOUTH ASIA.
GUESS WHAT?
1980, THEIR ECONOMY COLLAPSES
AND SOVIET UNION COLLAPSES OFF
THE BACK OF THE ARM WITH THE
LITTLE STINGER MISSILES.
THIS CAN BE SQUARED AS LONG AS
THEY.
UKRAINE PRESIDENT IS SUCH A
VALUABLE SYMBOL RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE DO WHATEVER WE CAN OR
WHATEVER IT IS A PRIVATE
SECURITY WHATEVER IT IS, WE HAVE
TO KEEP PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
ALIVE AND IN COUNTRY.
PUTIN CANNOT WIN IF THE UKRAINE
PRESIDENT IS ALIVE AND WELL AND
FIGHTING.
>> Jeanine: I DISAGREE WITH
THAT.
BECAUSE HE IS ALREADY SAID THAT
HE IS GOING TO TAKE THE LEADERS
WHO RESIST HIM AND PUT THEM ON
TRIAL.
HE BELIEVES IMPOSING PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF THE WORLD.
WHAT HE DID IN 2014.
THE SANCTIONS WORK?
BELORUSSIA ON THE PIPELINE SO HE
IS WITH THEM SO FAR.
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT WE HAVE
DONE THAT IS GIVEN PUTIN THE
BELIEF THAT HE CAN GET AWAY WITH
IT.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE
NO SANCTION AGAINST HIM
PERSONALLY.
IT'S LIKE ROCKING A TOUCH HIM.
IN THE INTERNATIONAL BANKING
SYSTEM, HOW IS HE GONNA SELL OIL
BE CAN'T GET THE MONEY FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL BANKING SYSTEM?
OKAY THERE HAS TO BE A WAY TO
CONVINCE ITALY AND THERE'S
PEOPLE WHO ARE DYING AS WE
SPEAK.
AND STOP TALK ABOUT TIME.
BECAUSE HE IS IN A POSITION TO
TAKE IN THE NEXT 24-48 HOURS.
THIS LONG-TERM SAVE THE
SANCTIONS AND PUTIN DOES NOT
CARE ABOUT IS PEOPLE,